And then lastly, let's go over some tips and tricks that you might be able to apply to
your foliage in the project. So we can restrict foliage placement. So we can do a number of
things to restrict the placement of foliage. In the advanced section here, which you can
see highlighted, you can define the landscape layers and this foliage should be allowed
on or not. So do you want to just place the foliage on specific layers, either add them
to the inclusion layers or the exclusion layers and this will give you much more control of
where you are placing the foliage. You can also adjust the ground slope angle to restrict
the slope at which the foliage will be placed. So that's always worth knowing. And then also
when we're looking at the landscape grass, the grass tool can be used to mask and adjust
the placement or you can just disable the setting like the placement jitter to make
something that looks like a field of crops. So, I mean, you can get some really, really nice results
by actually using these tools to create something a bit more uniform if that's something that you
want in your project. So when used with the foliage tools, the grass tools are really,
really powerful. So worth considering those as well. So to close out here, we've covered
foliage tools, the settings and the types, talked a little bit about LOD and hopefully giving you
some cool tips and tricks there at the end on your foliage settings. So let's go and close out the video.